Trascrizione: Giulia Santamaria
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Buongiorno a tutte e a tutti.
Sono molto contenta di essere qui oggi,
e di poter dare il mio contributo
a questo significativo evento.
Io nella vita, ormai -
Oltre ad avere come mission
quella di aiutarvi a dare un volto
all'assistente vocale che magari
è in molte delle vostre case -
eccolo qui, Alexa -
mi occupo di comunicazione.
Mi sono occupata
di comunicazione per molto tempo
e oggi vi parlo di questo,
di come il linguaggio ci possa aiutare
a promuovere il cambiamento.
Nel 2018 è stato celebrato
il primo centenario
del riconoscimento del voto
a una parte - non a tutte -
delle donne in Gran Bretagna.
È indubbio che, rispetto a questa foto,
molto è cambiato per le donne
da un punto di vista sociale,
politico, culturale,
economico e anche professionale,
anche se c'è sicuramente
del lavoro ancora da fare.
C'è un ambito, però, dove si fa fatica
a vedere il cambiamento succedere,
almeno nella stessa profondità e velocità
con cui dei cambiamenti
sono avvenuti negli altri ambiti.
Questo ambito a cui mi riferisco
è ovviamente il linguaggio.
Il linguaggio è qualcosa
da cui non possiamo prescindere,
fa parte di noi,
è una facoltà che abbiamo
quella di comunicare,
di entrare in relazione con altre persone,
da sempre, perché l'abbiamo appreso
nella primissima infanzia.
È impossibile ricordarci il momento
in cui abbiamo detto le prime parole,
o frasi di senso compiuto.
Siamo noi, è quello che facciamo
tutti i giorni come persone
e come professioniste e professionisti.
Potremmo quasi dire
che il linguaggio, in molti casi,
è come uno di quei muscoli
del nostro corpo
a cui sappiamo che il cervello
dà input per funzionare,
ma a cui non facciamo attenzione,
non è che ci stiamo lì a pensare.
E infatti succede così:
non pensiamo tanto al linguaggio,
andiamo un po' in automatico.
Se poi pensate alle tante cose
che facciamo contemporaneamente -
la telefonata, la mail,
la chat, mi giro, etc. -
il linguaggio è veloce e automatico,
quasi come queste attività,
che abbiamo appreso all'inizio -
andare in bicicletta, andare a correre -
e, a meno che uno non sia maniaco
di come mette gli arti inferiori
del proprio corpo,
prendi e vai.
E anzi, se superi i dieci minuti
di corsa, almeno io,
sono anche molto contenta,
non ci stai lì a pensare.
E con il linguaggio,
spesso ci succede così.
A meno che non siamo
in contesti molto formali
in cui devi fare estrema attenzione
a quello che dici,
a quello che scrivi etc.:
andiamo in automatico.
Questo può far sì che, inconsapevolmente,
nella migliore delle intenzioni -
non c'è cattiva fede, non c'è cattiveria,
non parliamo di linguaggio di odio,
parliamo di linguaggio d'uso quotidiano -
ci scappano via delle robe.
Ci scappano via delle cose
che veicolano, appunto,
stereotipi, preconcetti e retaggi
di un tempo che è stato
e che ci ha insegnato le espressioni
e il linguaggio che utilizziamo,
e che magari sta cercando
di cambiare nella realtà,
ma siccome è inchiodato
nel linguaggio e nelle espressioni
che invece continuiamo
a utilizzare in automatico,
cambia meno di quanto potrebbe.
Cioè, il linguaggio quasi fa da freno,
più che da aiuto al cambiamento,
non facendoci caso.
E questo ci succede in tantissimi ambiti:
su aspetti religiosi, su aspetti di età,
di etnia, di orientamento.
Oggi parliamo di genere
perché è questo su cui
vogliamo portare l'attenzione.
Quindi, adesso vi porto qualche esempio
per capire, un po' più nel concreto,
di cosa stiamo parlando.
Prendo un termine che in linguistica
è definito "epiceno".
Ovvero, quei termini
che di base non hanno genere
perché finiscono con la lettera "e"
e quindi li possiamo intendere,
in un modo o in un altro.
Prendo la parola "governante".
Se questo epiceno lo faccio precedere
da un articolo al maschile -
quindi "il governante" -
il mio pensiero probabilmente
va verso una persona
che decide, dirige, governa,
ha un ruolo di potere.
Se la stessa parola la faccio precedere
dall'equivalente articolo femminile,
di cui quindi l'epiceno prende il genere -
quindi "la governante" -
il mio pensiero andrà verso una persona
che sì dispone, ma lo fa
nell'ambito domestico e familiare,
probabilmente a supporto di altre persone.
Prendo invece un termine
che ha un genere di suo: "segretaria".
"Segretaria" identifica, nel mio pensiero,
una persona - la parola
fa sempre aprire del pensiero -
la parola mi fa pensare ad una persona
che ha probabilmente un ruolo
di assistenza e di supporto
ad altre persone.
Se invece questo termine
lo intendo al maschile,
cambiando semplicemente l'ultima lettera,
il mio pensiero - segretario di partito,
segretario di sindacato -
va invece verso una persona
che ha un ruolo di direzione,
di decisione, che stabilisce.
Quindi vediamo anche, di nuovo,
tornare un ruolo di potere.
Vedete come, nella nostra lingua,
soprattutto in riferimento
a parole che identificano ruoli,
esiste una certa disparità culturale
di quello che ci viene in mente
attraverso queste parole,
semplicemente utilizzandole.
Un altro passaggio che volevo fare
è proprio sull'uso
del maschile e del femminile
in generale nella nostra lingua.
Se dico "le clienti", "le colleghe",
"le responsabili",
è probabile che mi riferisca
alla porzione femminile
di questi tre gruppi -
anzi, certamente mi riferisco
alla porzione femminile di questi gruppi.
Se dico invece "i colleghi",
"i responsabili", "gli addetti",
mi potrei riferire
sia alla porzione equivalente maschile
di questi tre gruppi,
sia a ciascuno dei gruppi
nella loro totalità.
Questo perché l'italiano,
nella sua evoluzione dal latino,
ha perso il genere neutro
e ha assegnato al maschile
una sorta di doppio ruolo:
un ruolo di maschile -
che quindi, al pari del femminile,
identifica la porzione
maschile di un gruppo -
ma anche quello che viene
definito, in linguistica,
il "maschile generico",
o " maschile neutro",
quindi è il genere che utilizziamo
per individuare un gruppo -
io, qui, dovrei dire "voi tutti".
È però evidente,
avendo appreso anche questo
dalla primissima infanzia,
come - attraverso dei semini sottili,
quasi delle polveri sottili
come l'inquinamento -
nella nostra lingua
c'è una predominanza di maschile.
È così, ci hanno insegnato
che per parlare di tutti
usiamo il maschile.
E non il femminile,
che invece identifica una porzione.
Che poi tu dici:
"vabbè, ma questa si è fissata
su piccole cose: ma cosa ci cambia?
Abbiamo sempre fatto così,
adesso ci dobbiamo fissare
su queste cose?"
Ci sono tantissimi studi
di linguistica e psicologia
che dimostrano come,
all'interno delle organizzazioni
oggetto di questi studi,
la popolazione femminile
che è ripetutamente, per lungo tempo,
esposta a un linguaggio che è
in modo predominante, se non esclusivo,
fatto di maschile generico -
quindi "i dipendenti",
"i colleghi", espressioni così -
ha un impatto misurato
sul proprio senso di appartenenza,
di ingaggio emotivo, di partecipazione,
di motivazione nel lavoro che fa.
Ovviamente anche con una ricaduta
sulla propria produttività
all'interno dell'organizzazione,
sulla fiducia in sé stesse,
che queste donne e ragazze
portano nel lavoro,
quella voglia di buttarsi
e di cogliere delle nuove opportunità,
di spingersi.
Quindi, cominciamo
a misurare questo impatto.
E se avviene nelle organizzazioni
oggetto di questi studi,
è molto probabile che, a macchia d'olio,
riguardi più o meno
tutte le organizzazioni,
e quindi abbia un impatto
sul sistema Paese.
Che guardacaso,
ha un livello di occupazione femminile -
lo si citava prima -
inferiore a quello
delle medie di altri Paesi.
Non sarà certo questo l'unico elemento
che porta a questo numero,
però può dare il suo contributo.
Quindi, forse il farci caso
ha un certo ruolo, una certa valenza.
Volevo fare, sempre a proposito
di termini e di parole,
un altro passaggio.
Se dico "infermiera"
non c'è niente di strano,
è un termine che viene utilizzato
moltissime volte.
Così come "ragioniera", un altro termine
di uso assolutamente comune.
Se invece dico un'altra parola,
che paradossalmente fa parte
di questa stessa famiglia,
come classificazione grammaticale,
che è "ingegnera" -
la desinenza è uguale.
Non è che voglio fare
il sofismo linguistico,
però "infermiera" e "ragioniera"
non ci pongono dei problemi,
ma se dico "ingegnera" sono strana,
diciamo la verità,
le facce diventano più strane.
Anche "impiegata" è una parola
che usiamo tutti -
io sono stata impiegata
per tantissimi anni -
è assolutamente di uso normale.
Anche qui, metto una parola
che fa parte della stessa famiglia,
ma che magari è
meno frequente: "avvocata".
Ah, perché "avvocata",
quindi, lo possiamo dire?
Non è "avvocatessa", "avvocato"?
Allora, sarebbe meglio dire,
come diciamo "impiegata" -
anche qui, stessa famiglia
e stesso funzionamento linguistico -
"avvocata".
Questa è la formula corretta.
"Direttrice" della scuola:
chi non ne ha incontrata una
nella propria vita, anche scolastica?
C'è chi dice che dovremmo
dire "direttora":
ma facciamo un passo alla volta,
agganciamoci a "direttrice".
Quindi, con "direttrice" della scuola
nessun problema, tutto a posto.
"Direttrice" generale,
"direttrice" del personale,
"direttrice" di stabilimento,
e potrei andare avanti a farvi esempi.
Qui, a volte sì a volte no,
a volte fa strano altre volte no, boh.
"Amministratrice" della casa:
abbiamo detto che tante donne, magari,
rinunciano alla loro vita professionale
e le potremmo definire
"amministratrici" della casa:
nessun problema.
"Amministratrice" delegata.
Anche qua, grammaticalmente nulla
ci esclude di usare quest'espressione.
Perché per la casa sì e per l'azienda no?
Quando provo a far presente
questa possibilità di denominazione
alle donne che hanno questi ruoli
di vertice, di responsabilità,
alla guida delle aziende,
il non verbale - perché è così
che mi torna indietro -
che mi viene restituito è:
"ma dopo tutta la fatica che ho fatto
per arrivare dove sono -
e siamo anche poche -
mi devo far chiamare
con uno scioglilingua?"
Ma perché starci
a interrogare su queste cose
se, in fondo, abbiamo
da sempre l'abitudine
ad usare più il maschile del femminile
perché ci è più comodo e più veloce?
E anche se le donne, a volte,
hanno il titolo professionale
al maschile piuttosto che al femminile,
vorremmo mica dire
che le donne sono più o meno brave
se le chiamiamo
col maschile o col femminile?
Guardiamo altre cose, no?
Guardiamo le qualità,
i risultati, le competenze...
Che poi, anche se i termini al femminile
sono meno valorizzanti
di quelli al maschile,
in fondo perché stare tanto
a questionare su queste cose?
A parte magari la mia naturale passione
per questi temi, perché?
Perché ho imparato, dagli studi esistenti,
che è importante chiamare
le cose con il loro nome,
perché per come funzioniamo
da un punto di vista cognitivo -
i nostri meccanismi cognitivi -
un qualcosa non esiste se non ha un nome.
È un po' come il file nel computer:
se non ho il nome del file,
non lo trovo più.
Allora, per come funzioniamo,
abbiamo bisogno dei nomi
per creare categorie
e immagazzinare delle informazioni.
Altrimenti, non riesco
a entrare in relazione:
"come si chiama cosa?" "mi passi il coso?"
È evidente che non ho
una relazione significativa,
né con l'oggetto né con la persona.
E che relazione posso avere
con una donna che raggiunge
una posizione decisionale,
però si chiama come un uomo?
È evidente che c'è qualcosa che stride,
qualcosa che non torna.
E questo continuare
a non usare il femminile
nei modi e nei contesti
in cui sarebbe invece opportuno farlo
continua a nascondere
la presenza del femminile,
che invece sta arrivando
ai ruoli decisionali,
si sta facendo avanti
e si deve fare avanti.
E imprigioniamo invece il femminile
in quest'uso ancora
patriarcale del linguaggio,
che ci arriva dai tempi che furono,
ma che può fare la sua evoluzione.
È assolutamente
alla portata del linguaggio.
E il fatto che io sia una donna
non deve far pensare che queste siano
le solite questioni "da donna","tra donne"
che cercano sempre
di scalpitare, di farsi avanti.
Questo non è un discorso
che riguarda solo le donne,
perché parliamo di femminile.
Riguarda le donne e riguarda gli uomini.
Riguarda tutte e tutti.
Perché le donne, oggi,
non sono una piccola minoranza
che dobbiamo andare
a proteggere, poverine.
Sono il 52 percento della popolazione,
sono il 60 percento
di chi consegue una laurea in Italia -
lascio stare la votazione
che, in media, è più alta -
e hanno in mano - per via diretta
o per forte influenza -
fino all'85 percento
di tutte le decisioni di acquisto.
Ma non solo dei prodotti per la casa,
o per l'igiene della persona.
Parliamo di prodotti
di elettronica, di macchine,
di prodotti di risparmio
finanziario e assicurativi,
tradizionalmente associati
all'area del maschile.
Quindi è un enorme bacino
di influenza, decisione e di acquisto -
che quindi muove quote di mercato -
che non è rappresentato
in una maniera coerente, corretta,
nel nostro linguaggio di tutti i giorni.
Con in più un impatto,
come dicevamo prima,
sul senso di motivazione, partecipazione,
autostima di questa popolazione,
che può fare la differenza nei numeri,
nelle organizzazioni e nel sistema Paese.
E invece, continuando
con il nostro linguaggio,
in qualche modo rimarchiamo il fatto
che avere donne in ruoli apicali,
è un'eccezione a una regola,
perché numericamente e statisticamente
sono sempre più gli uomini, che lo fanno.
Invece, chiamiamo le cose
con il loro nome.
E se vogliamo che qualcosa cambi,
non dobbiamo aspettare che se ne occupino
le istituzioni, la politica, i media, etc.
Possiamo fare subito
qualcosa, tutte e tutti,
iniziando a parlare
la lingua dell'inclusione.
Iniziando a farci più caso,
a renderci conto delle cose che diciamo
e di che cosa vogliono dire
le parole che usiamo,
i titoli professionali, ecc.
Perché, se continuiamo a considerare
le espressioni,
i modi di dire, la battuta -
"Dai, che vuoi che sia,
stai a guardare queste cose?"-
come episodi isolati,
allora ci potremmo anche dire
che non hanno gran peso;
ma se invece le immaginiamo
come tasselli di un mosaico,
ognuna di quelle espressioni,
modi di dire, battute
ha un peso nell'aiutarci
a definire un'immagine complessiva;
o a modificarla, se vogliamo che cambi.
E quindi, bisogna lavorare
in maniera certosina
sulle espressioni di tutti i giorni,
su quelle piccole cose di tutti i giorni
del parlare la lingua dell'inclusione,
diventando artigiane e artigiani
del nostro linguaggio.
Nelle piccole cose, è così che cambierà.
Come diceva Wittgenstein,
filosofo del linguaggio
della prima parte del 900,
"I limiti del mio linguaggio
sono i limiti del mio mondo."
Inventare nuovi usi,
talvolta assurdi, delle parole
può essere l'unico modo
per allentare le maglie
dell'uso abituale del linguaggio.
Grazie.
(Applausi)